The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
We were talking about factors
affecting the rates of reaction.
And so we have gone through a
number of these.
We talked last class about the
affect of temperature.
We talked about mechanism last
Wednesday, we talked about
nature of material and
concentrations in the lectures
preceding that,
and now we are up to the last
thing that we had on our
original list,
which are catalysts.
Today we are going to talk
about catalysis.
This is on the lecture
summaries that will arrive for
you.
A catalyst is a substance that
takes part in the reaction but
is not consumed in the reaction.
It is a bystander of the
reaction.
It will speed it up,
but it does not undergo any
permanent change itself.
That is the definition of a
catalyst.
Catalysts, because they are not
changing in their form,
are not part of an overall
balanced equation.
Sometimes you will see a
balanced equation and a thing
over the arrow,
which will indicate the
conditions in which the reaction
was done.
And often information about a
catalyst that was used in the
reaction will be present there.
What are catalysts actually
doing?
Here is the potential energy
diagram that we looked at last
time.
And in this diagram you have
some energy for reactants.
Energy for products down here.
There is an overall change,
delta E, between the reactants
and the products.
And, again, delta E is very
similar to delta H.
It is only 1% or 2% off for
gases and almost the same for
liquids and solids.
It is information about the
thermodynamics.
This is a calorimetry,
a thermodynamic measurement.
And then we saw that there is
an activation energy.
This is at Ea for the forward
reaction that the molecules need
to overcome, a critical energy
that they need to overcome
before they can go on and form
products.
That energy barrier is there
because when molecules come
together and attempt to react,
usually there is some amount of
bond distortion that has to
occur, things are rearranging,
and you form,
usually, some kind of
intermediate activated complex
or transition state.
And, when you get up there,
if the molecules have enough
energy to react,
then they can go to products.
If they don't have enough
energy to react,
if there is not enough energy
to distort those bonds and form
this activated complex,
then they will fall back apart
to reactants.
For an elementary reaction,
there is always some barrier to
overcome.
And I think about activation
energy barriers in my own work
all the time.
It seems like whenever I have
to sit down and do something,
start writing a paper,
write a grant,
write the final exam,
there always seems to be some
activation energy barrier to
getting started.
And, once you get started,
if you get to this point,
then it is all downhill,
and things go much more
smoothly.
But, in the beginning,
it always seems like every
reaction or every task has some
kind of activation energy
barrier.
Up at this top part there,
with this dash line,
then there is a transition
state or an activated complex.
And here is the barrier without
the catalyst,
here is the energy barrier
without the catalyst and the
line for the transition state.
And, again, if we go in the
reverse direction of this,
there is an activation energy
for the reverse reaction here.
And these will all sum up,
so delta E is going to be equal
to the activation energy for the
forward reaction minus the
activation energy for the
reverse reaction.
What does adding a catalyst do?
Well, adding a catalyst lowers
that activation energy barrier.
That is shown here in the blue
line.
And this is also in the
handout.
This is the energy barrier with
a catalyst, so it is lower.
And then the transition state
with a catalyst will also be
lower.
And so one way that you can
think about this is that a
catalyst lowers or stabilizes
the transition state.
All right.
Let's add a few more things to
this diagram,
then.
There will be a new activation
energy for the forward reaction,
shown in blue.
It is not as high a barrier
now.
It's lowered down.
And there will be a new
activation energy for the
reverse reaction,
shown in blue.
These are the values then with
the catalyst.
A catalyst is going to lower
both the activation energy for
the forward reaction and the
activation energy for the
reverse reaction.
And that is what is said here.
It lowers both barriers,
forward and reverse.
And another way to express this
is that the catalysts stabilize
this transition state or
activated complex.
They are going to lower the
energy or stabilize this state.
And this way of thinking about
this, we will come back to at
the end of the lecture.
It is something that is used by
pharmaceutical companies in
terms of designing inhibitors of
enzymes to think about this.
Catalysts have no affect on the
thermodynamics of the reaction.
They are affecting the rate of
the reaction but not the
thermodynamics of the reaction.
You see that delta E is not
changing in this at all.
It is the same energy
difference between reactants and
products.
That term is not changing,
and also delta G would not
change.
Delta G is a state function.
It is independent of the path,
so it is not going to change.
It does not care if it had to
go over a higher barrier or a
lower barrier.
It is independent of the path
of the reaction.
It just cares about where it
ends up.
Delta G is not going to change
with a catalyst.
Therefore, equilibrium constant
is not going to change with a
catalyst.
What you are changing is the
activation energy barriers,
again, the forward and reverse
reaction, and you are speeding
up, then, the reaction.
The Chinese symbol for a
catalyst is a marriage
counselor.
You can think about the
catalyst as really facilitating
those molecules coming together
and having enough energy to
react.
Say, if they were at a lower
temperature, it would be harder
to get over that activation
energy barrier.
A catalyst, or a molecule
counselor will help lower that
barrier and make it more likely
for these molecules to have that
energy to react and go onto
product.
And that will speed up the
reaction.
We talked last time about if
you are at high temperature or
low temperature.
If you are at higher
temperature, more molecules can
overcome the barrier.
Lower temperature makes it
harder to do that.
A catalyst facilitates things
by making the barrier lower.
That is what a catalyst can do.
And, in terms of your own
thinking about things,
if you have big activation
energy barriers for,
say, studying for things or
writing a final paper.
You can think of catalysts as
being the due date being the
next day, so you have run out of
time.
That can be a big catalyst and
lowering that barrier and
helping you get started.
Caffeine works for a lot of
people in terms of getting over
those activation energy
barriers.
You can think about in your own
life, what are good catalysts
that help you get over those
barriers?
Okay.
An inhibitor,
then, would be the opposite of
a catalyst.
And it will slow the rate of a
reaction.
And it can increase the
activation energy barrier.
An inhibitor is going to be the
opposite.
And, again, we will talk more
about inhibitors at the end of
today's class.
There are a couple types of
catalysts.
You can talk about homogenous
And that is when the reactant
and the catalyst are in the same
phase.
An example would be in the
depletion of the ozone layer by
chlorofluorocarbons.
Those are all in the gas phase,
so this acts as a catalyst.
It catalyzes the depletion of
ozone, which is why people have
been very concerned about spray
cans and other things that
release these molecules into the
environment.
You can also have heterogeneous
catalysts, so something that is
in a different phase as the
reacting molecules.
And we are all familiar with
examples of this,
like a catalytic converter.
In this case,
your catalyst would be solid
metals, platinum,
paladium, rhodium.
And they will help catalyze
oxidation of hydrocarbons,
CO gases, reduction of nitrogen
oxides, so to reduce pollution.
The reactant molecules are
gases, but the catalyst is a
metal.
It is heterogeneous.
It is in a different phase.
So, these two examples.
I will just show you a little
movie of heterogeneous
catalysis.
Could some of the TAs help?
The lecture notes are here.
This movie is not in the
lectures notes.
We have here a metal surface in
blue.
And the metal is acting as a
catalyst.
And in gray we have these two
dots.
Those are hydrogens.
What the metal did was help to
facilitate the dissociation
of H two.
H two, which is not so
reactive, has been dissociated,
and you have broken into the
two separate hydrogens.
And now if we bring in a
molecule of ethane,
then it will react with this.
You have a molecule come in,
in a different phase.
And see how the hydrogens just
kind of bop right onto the
molecule?
The metal surface was acting as
a catalyst, making the H two
gas, I will just do that
one more time,
more reactive by having it
dissociate first.
Now they are sitting on the
metal surface,
and the reaction is quite a bit
faster.
That would be an example of the
heterogeneous catalysis.
All right.
Now, I am going to talk about
my favorite kind of catalysts,
catalysts of life,
or enzymes.
Enzymes are catalysts.
And if you are a biochemist,
enzymes are your favorite kind
of catalyst.
An enzyme is usually a protein.
There are some examples of RNA
catalyzing reactions,
but most enzymes are made up of
protein.
And they are usually fairly
large.
The sort of smallest molecular
weight you might see would be
about 20,000 grams per mole.
Again, some people on Exam 3,
I will just point this out,
when I asked for units of
molecular weight,
grams per mole,
some people didn't have the
right units for that.
And that is the same molecular
weight if you are talking about
a weak acid or you are talking
about an enzyme.
Same units but different size.
These enzymes are capable of
catalyzing a wide variety of
different reactions in your
body.
Proteins or enzymes are made up
of amino acids.
And amino acids have carbon,
nitrogen, oxygen,
and sulfur in them.
And I will share with you a
little recent story.
We have a collaborator who is
in France.
They tried to send us some
protein to do crystallization
experiments.
I got a call from Customs.
There was a Dewar with this
protein sitting in New Jersey.
And Customs was calling me and
said, they couldn't release this
material from Customs without
more information.
They said, it says here that
the Dewar contains protein,
and we need to know what that
protein is made of.
And we also need to know who
had manufactured the protein.
And so now you can all answer
the question if Customs calls.
Proteins are made up of amino
acids.
I am not really sure what they
were getting at here.
And, in terms of who had
manufactured it,
it was E.
coli bacteria.
We were actually afraid of
saying that, because there are
strains of E.
coli that seem to every once in
a while make people very sick at
McDonald's and White Castle and
places like that.
E.
coli has now become sort of a
dangerous bacteria,
so we said the protein was made
up of amino acids,
like you buy at the health food
store, and the manufacturer was
"natural sources."
The protein was released to us,
but apparently the person at
Customs had not had much
chemistry or biochemistry in
their background.
All right.
Proteins are made up of these
amino acids.
Here is an amino acid.
Professor Ceyer talked about
this before in terms of "bad
hair days".
Amino acid.
Here we have an amino group,
a carboxylic group and a
carbon, which is called alpha
carbon.
It is sitting in the middle.
And there is a group R,
and that can be 20 different
kinds of side chains that make
up the 20 amino acids that are
commonly found in proteins.
And so one amino acid gets
linked to another amino acid
through what is called the
peptide bond shown here.
And so here we have our first
amino acid and our second.
Again, you can have hundreds
and hundreds of amino acids
connected to each other.
Then they fold up into some
kind of compact structure for
the enzyme.
In this particular case,
there are four different chains
of peptides.
Each chain has 198 amino acids.
Each chain in this picture is
shown in a different color,
yellow, green,
red, and blue.
And in these diagrams,
they don't show all the atoms,
because that would just kind of
be a big mess,
if you showed all the atoms.
Instead, a ribbon is drawn
through the positions of the
alpha carbons of every amino
acid.
And so these kind of squiggly
things here are alpha helices,
which is one type of secondary
structure.
You will learn about that in
5.07 or 7.05.
Arrows are often indicated
what's called beta sheets,
extended regions of the amino
acids.
And so think kind of gives you
a general sense of what we call
the folds of the protein in
these diagrams.
And so this gives you a sense
of how big this molecule
actually is.
And we report things in
angstroms, typically,
because that is a good unit of
measure that helps tell you
about how far apart the atoms
are in structures.
What is this particular enzyme?
Well, this particular enzyme is
involved in catalyzing the last
step in the biosynthesis of an
antibiotic called phosphomycin.
And so this is the reactant or
substrate.
And this is the product,
phosphomycin.
What phosphomycin does is
inhibits cell wall biosynthesis
of bacteria and forms a covalent
adduct with amino acid in the
active site of one of the
important enzymes in cell wall
biosynthesis.
And so a lot of antibiotics
target cell wall biosynthesis.
It was first approved to treat
mostly like bladder infections
and sort of more minor types of
infections, but recently,
they found that it works
against strains of
Staphylococcus aureus infection,
which is pretty serious.
There are several strains of
staph infection now that are
resistant to some of the
powerful kinds of antibiotics
that had been used before.
And so they are looking for new
antibiotics that might be
successful in treating those
infections.
Antibiotic resistance of
certain kinds of bacteria has
become a really enormous
problem, and is just getting
worse.
I always like to ask a crowd
like this, how many have taken
antibiotics zero times in their
life, first?
Never taken antibiotics.
I don't see anybody.
How about once?
Three people.
Twice?
A few more.
Three times?
You probably don't remember.
Say around maybe five or more
or something like that?
OK.
You can see,
from looking around,
why this is a problem.
Bacteria are clever.
They figure out and try to get
around ways, because they want
to survive, so there is some
nice natural selection going on.
And there are actually
resistant strains to
phosphomycin as well.
And what happens in that case,
as I said, is it works by
becoming attached to an amino
acid, and then the enzyme is
dead.
But if that amino acid is
mutated, it is a cysteine.
If it mutates to an aspartic
acid, then it can no longer be
inhibited by this and it still
works.
It is not as good an enzyme but
still works.
If there is pressure applied,
natural selection,
die or mutate,
a lot of things will be very
happy to mutate if they can.
Some of the antibiotics,
if it mutates,
only just one amino acid
changes, all of a sudden there
is a resistance going on.
The more times that bacteria
are exposed to antibiotics,
the more likely it is they will
mutate in such a way that they
will be resistant in the future.
This is a really huge problem.
If you're thinking,
I'm interested in science,
what should I do with my life?
This is one thing that you
might want to think about.
A lot of what we take
antibiotics for used to be
conditions that were deadly.
If we don't have antibiotics,
then life expectancy is quite a
bit different.
Anyway, this is one of the
projects in my lab.
We're looking at a number of
different enzymes that are
involved in antibiotic
biosynthesis.
All right.
Enzyme catalysis.
I am going to introduce you to
a few terms.
And then what we are going to
do is we are going to use the
things that you learned,
mostly last Wednesday,
on mechanism of reactions.
And we are going to derive the
Michaelis-Menten equations for
enzyme kinetics.
You might not have realized
that on Wednesday you were
learning all the sort of tools
you need in biochemistry,
you weren't actually learning
biochemistry,
but you were.
And I think you will see that
now.
First, a couple of new terms.
I already introduced this a
little bit, but reactant
molecules, we're always talking
about reactants.
When you are talking about
enzymes, you are talking about
substrates.
We no longer call them
reactants.
We now call them substrates.
Substrates bind to what is
known as the active site of the
enzyme.
That is the site where
catalysis occurs,
so it is active.
That is pretty easy to
remember.
Here is a very simple enzyme
reaction.
And a lot of enzyme reactions
actually are fairly simple.
Here, you would have an enzyme
binding to your substrate.
Enzyme called E.
Substrate called S.
When the substrate binds to the
enzyme, it forms an enzyme
substrate complex,
which is known as an ES
complex.
That enzyme substrate complex,
or ES complex,
will go on and form enzyme E
and product P.
Just to show that in cartoon
form, and it pains me to do
this, to draw the enzyme like
this.
Because, as you saw in the last
slide, enzymes are really quite
beautiful.
And this is a very sad
description of what an enzyme
looks like.
Also, here the substrate is
about the size of the enzyme,
which is also all off.
But here is a substrate binding
the enzyme.
This would be the active site
and would be designed just to
fit the substrate in there quite
nicely.
When substrate binds to the
enzyme, you form what is known
as the ES complex.
And usually this binding is
reversible.
Not all substrate that binds to
the enzyme will go on to form
product.
Some will go back and form free
substrate and enzyme.
And, in this drawing,
then when the enzyme reacts on
the substrate,
it will form product and free
enzyme again.
And this is drawn with a single
line as not being a reversible
step in the reaction.
Here you see substrate,
and what this enzyme did is
sort of make the substrate look
a little more like Mickey Mouse.
There is our product coming
off.
Now we can derive equations to
represent that reaction that I
just showed you.
And we can use all the same
ideas that we had when we were
deriving mechanisms in class
last Wednesday and on Problem
Set 10.
Again, the reaction is enzyme
plus substrate,
E plus S going in a reversible
step to the enzyme substrate
complex ES,
and then going with a single
non-reversible step to enzyme
and product.
We can put this in two steps.
Step 1 is the reversible step
of enzyme and substrate going to
the enzyme substrate complex
with rate constants k one
for forward step and k minus one
for the reverse step.
In Step 2, we have the enzyme
substrate complex going to
enzyme and product with rate
constant k two.
These then are elementary
reactions, and so we can write
the rate law for each step just
based as how the reaction is
written.
What would be the rate for the
forward reaction?
k one times E times S.
All right.
There is the rate for the
forward reaction.
Again, just based on rate
constant times the two things
that are reacting.
What about for the reverse
reaction?
What's the rate constant?
k minus one times ES,
right.
That would be for the reverse
reaction.
And what about the rate for
Step 2?
K two times ES,
right. Okay.
Now we can look at the rate of
formation of product,
the overall reaction.
The rate of product formation
can be expressed as the change
dP / dt, with time,
for product.
And also we can just write it
from the second step in terms of
k two times ES.
That is the
rate of formation of product.
Are we done?
No, because why?
There is an intermediate,
so we have to solve for the
intermediate.
Again, this should seem
familiar.
It is all the same stuff we
were talking about last week.
We need to solve for the
intermediate.
We are not given anything about
fast and slow steps,
so we are going to use the
steady-state approximation which
is going to tell you that the
net formation of intermediates
is pretty much constant.
It is in the steady-state.
Another way to express that is
that all the steps that form the
intermediate are equal in rate
to all the steps that get rid of
that intermediate --
-- either consume it or
decompose it.
First, we need to look at what
all the steps are that have to
do with the intermediate.
Here is the rate of the
formation of that intermediate.
And so that is going to be
equal to the steps involved in
forming the intermediate.
And it is only formed in that
first step, forward direction of
the first step.
Its rate k one times the
concentration of E times the
concentration of S.
That's the rate
of formation.
And then, we are going to
subtract from that steps that
are involved in the
decomposition or in the
consumption of the intermediate.
The intermediate decomposes in
the reverse direction of Step 1.
That is this rate,
k minus one times ES.
And it is also consumed in this
second step.
It is consumed by the rate k
two times ES.
Again, this is exactly the same
as what we looked at last week.
Now we can consider the
steady-state approximation,
and we can set that whole term
equal to zero.
Steady-state again,
the net rate of formation of
the intermediate is equal to the
net rate at which it goes away.
The whole equation can be set
equal to zero.
We can do that here,
set this term equal to zero.
Now, there is a slight change.
It is not 100% what we did
before.
There is a slight change.
And that comes out of a
practical consideration.
When you are doing these
experiments, in the term that we
had, you usually don't know how
much enzyme is free.
And it is hard to figure that
out, at any one time,
how much enzyme is not reacting
with a substrate.
It is much easier to know how
much enzyme you added to the
reaction to begin with.
That is a number that you
should know.
You should have carefully
figured out how much enzyme that
you were going to use in your
experiment.
Instead of solving for the
intermediate in terms of the
free enzyme, it is easier to
solve for it in terms of the
total enzyme,
which we are going to call E
nought, how much enzyme you put
into the equation.
The total enzyme that is
reacting with substrate that you
put into the experiment would
equal the amount that is free,
the amount that is not reacting
at any given time or that just
finished reacting,
and the amount of the enzyme
that is bound.
It is only going to be free or
bound.
The total enzyme equals these
two.
And so you can go back to your
other equation,
right now.
And whenever you had free
enzyme, you can substitute in
terms for total enzyme minus
bound, because that is going to
be equal to free.
Again, this is just a practical
consideration that it is easier,
if you are doing these
experiments, and,
again, biochemistry is an
experimental science,
to know how much enzyme you
started with than to know how
much is non-reacting at any
given time.
This is just a practical thing.
And for all the other things we
worked on, you are always
wanting to solve for the
intermediate in terms of things
you could measure like rate
constants and concentration of
reactants or products.
It is a similar kind of idea.
You want to be able to solve
for things in terms of stuff
that you can actually measure.
Now we can go back.
Again, this is the equation
that we were solving for our
intermediate.
If you use the steady-state
approximation,
you set the whole term equal to
zero.
Now we can take this term and
substitute.
We are going to replace this E,
and that is the only free
enzyme that we had in this whole
expression.
We are going to replace this
now with total enzyme minus the
bound enzyme.
We are going to put that term
in here, and that gives us the
following.
Now we have k one S
times, in parentheses,
this term, which equals free
enzyme, total minus bound.
And now we can multiply that
out.
K one S times total enzyme
here.
And then there is a minus here.
We have k one ES times
substrate, over here.
And these parts are unchanged.
Now we can solve for ES.
Here is our expression from the
last sheet.
Now we can rearrange to solve
for ES.
We are going to put all the ES
terms onto one side.
Here is an ES term,
here was an ES term,
and here was an ES term,
so we moved those down to the
other side of the equation.
It gets rid of the negative.
Bring that over.
And the only thing on the other
side of the equation is this
term here, k one times
total enzyme times substrate.
Now we can go ahead,
as we did before,
and pull out all of these ES
terms and come up with an
expression that solves for it.
So we are going to solve for
ES.
We pulled out ES,
here.
We have k one S,
we have k minus one,
and we have k two.
We have this expression over
here.
And now we can take this
expression and divide by that
term.
And so this gives us an
expression, then,
for the concentration of our
intermediate.
Now we are going to do one
other thing that is a bit
different.
This term has a lot of k's in
it.
And so we are going to
substitute these k's for another
term that is more convenient to
measure than any of these are by
themselves.
Again, this is a practical
consideration.
You want to be able to use
these equations to get
information about enzyme
kinetics.
And so the term that we are
going to introduce is called big
K to the little m,
the Michaelis-Menten constant.
And so the Michaelis-Menten
constant, we will talk about
what this really means,
what this constant means in
practical terms in a couple
minutes, Km equals k minus one
plus k two divided by k one.
Now we somehow want to get this
term into this expression.
Here is the expression again.
We want this term in here.
If you notice at the bottom
here, there is a k minus one and
a k two, just like there is
here.
If we divided these two by k
one, we would have Km
over here.
But, if we do that,
we have to divide everything by
k one.
Let's divide everything by k
one and turn this part of the
expression into a Km.
If we do that,
we divide the top term by
k one, we divide this term
here, k one S,
by k one, and we divided these
two by k one.
We do that because now this is
going to be equal to Km.
All right.
We can simplify this
expression.
We have various things that we
can cross out.
If we do that,
you can cross these two out,
up here.
You can also cross these two
out, down here.
And what does that leave us
with?
That leaves us with this.
The top term,
we have total enzyme
concentration times substrate
concentration over substrate
concentration plus this term
here, which is Km.
We have taken something that
was a little bit more clunky and
turned it into an expression
that has fewer terms,
including this new term that is
used for enzyme kinetics,
this Km term.
Now, we can finally go back and
take our term for the
concentration of the
intermediate and plug it into
our rate law for formation of
product.
Again, this was our expression
for the rate of product
formation, k two times the
concentration of ES.
And we can take this and plug
that in here.
And that gives us this term,
k two, times total enzyme times
substrate over substrate plus
Km.
And this is the
Michaelis-Menten equation.
We used the steady-state
approximation.
We solved for an intermediate.
We did two things differently.
We didn't solve for free
enzyme.
We solved for total enzyme.
And we also introduced this
term, Km, and took out some of
the individual rate constants
and expressed them in terms of
this constant.
Here is our rate equation for
formation of product.
Now let's think about what this
equation can do,
what it means,
what happens when enzyme is
making product,
is acting as the catalyst and
turning our substrate into
product.
Here would be a graph of what
it might look like.
You have, here,
the rate of formation of
product expressed as dP / dt.
That is just rate of product
formation versus substrate
concentration.
And you see that the curve goes
up and then levels off.
What is happening in this case?
Well, at low substrate
concentration and down here,
this is low substrate
concentration,
when you add more substrate,
the rate goes up quite quickly
and then starts to level off.
And at low substrate
concentration,
adding more substrate increases
the rate a lot,
because there is a bunch of
enzyme that is free,
that is just hanging out.
And it is not making product
because it doesn't have any
substrate.
But you give it substrate and
it will quickly make product.
That is what is happening.
You have lots of free enzyme
around.
It is ready for substrate.
When you add substrate,
it reacts.
Lots of product is formed.
Why would it level off?
Well, it will level off at
higher substrate concentrations
because, at higher substrate
concentrations,
there really is any free enzyme
around anymore.
Adding more substrate,
when the enzyme already has
substrate bound,
is not going to increase the
rate at which the product is
being formed.
We say that the enzyme is
saturated.
The enzyme already has as much
substrate as it can use.
And you just have to wait until
it finishes the reaction to
product before a new substrate
can be bound.
The rate is going to level off
at some point,
because there is no free enzyme
around.
You have saturated with
substrate.
Adding more does not help your
rate.
We can think about this in
terms of the Michaelis-Menten
equation.
We can think about when
substrate concentrations are
really high, when you have lots
of substrates.
And we can think about that in
terms of this value for Km.
Again, we are looking here at
the bottom of this equation,
and we are thinking about,
how big is this term compared
to that term.
Under conditions of the
experiment, where substrate
concentration is a much bigger
number than Km,
we can get rid of the Km term,
so we can cross this out.
Again, if you have a really big
number in the denominator added
to a much smaller number.
The much smaller number is not
really contributing much,
and you can just get rid of it.
Now, we can simplify this
equation then,
if we did that.
What else could we cancel out?
We can cancel out S.
We can get rid of our
substrate.
And that leaves us with this
expression.
That the rate of formation of
product under these conditions,
when substrate is a much bigger
number than this Km term,
then we get this expression,
that the rate is just equal to
k two times the total enzyme
that we had in our reaction.
And this has a name.
It is called V(max).
V(max) equals k two times total
enzyme, and V(max) is the
maximum rate of the reaction.
And so, when you have lots and
lots of substrates,
you are under these conditions,
where you can determine the
maximum rate of the enzyme.
The V(max) of the enzyme.
And it is only equal to this k
two times how much enzyme you
had in that particular
experiment.
Again, the maximum rate of the
enzyme under these conditions.
Again, that would be up here.
The rate levels off.
When you have high substrate
concentration,
then you are at the maximum
rate.
The enzyme cannot go any faster
at that point.
The rate depends on how much
enzyme you have and the k two
term.
Now, let's consider this
scenario, where these two terms
at the bottom of the expression
are equal to each other,
when substrate equals Km,
the concentration of substrate
equals Km.
If those are equal,
we can get rid of the Km term
and put in another substrate
term, because they are equal.
We will just put in another
substrate term.
Then we can simplify again.
Two substrates are down here.
One is up here.
We can cancel one of them and
get the following.
We cancel one.
We have one-half k two
times the total enzyme
concentration.
And this would be then the half
maximal rate.
The maximal rate was k two
times the total enzyme
concentration.
Half maximal is half that rate.
And now we can finally define
Km.
We can define Km as the
concentration of substrate for
which the rate is half maximal.
The concentration of substrate,
when you have this half maximal
rate.
That is what Km is.
And so this is a term that is
easy to measure,
then.
That is why we did some
manipulations to get it into our
equation, because it is a term
where you can find the answer,
the Km value.
If you know the maximal rate,
you can find the half maximal
rate and figure out what
substrate concentration gives
you that half maximal rate.
And that is just going to be
your Km.
In some problems that you are
going to have,
and the extra problems that are
posted, it may tell you the
maximal rate and then tell you
the substrate concentration that
gives you the half maximal rate
and you have to find the Km.
Well, that is not a hard
problem.
If you are told the substrate
concentration that gives you the
half maximal rate,
that is the Km.
It is just a matter of knowing
the definition.
The levels of problems that you
have in your chapter on enzyme
kinetics are really pretty
simple.
If you know some of the
definitions, you are all set.
Finally, let's just look at
inhibitors in the last few
minutes.
This is a very simplistic view
of an inhibitor situation.
If your inhibitor is I,
it may bind to your free enzyme
to give you an EI complex,
an inhibitor bound complex.
If the inhibitor is bound in
the active site,
and it is bound pretty well,
substrate is going to come
along.
But it cannot bind,
so you cannot make any product.
The inhibitor has stopped the
activity.
That is just a very simplistic
scheme of what can be going on.
Many pharmaceuticals work on
enzyme inhibitors.
That is what they do.
They stop enzyme biological
catalysts.
The way in which they work,
often, is that the inhibitor is
designed to mimic the transition
state of the reaction.
If you have things coming
together and they form an
activated complex or a
transition state before they go
on to, say, form products,
often the inhibitor is designed
to look like that transition
state that is formed.
The reason why it would do this
is because molecules that
resemble the transition state
should bind more tightly to the
enzyme than either the reactants
or the products.
Therefore, they can serve as
effective inhibitors.
If you just recall what we
showed at the beginning of the
talk, catalysts work by lowering
this barrier,
or by stabilizing the
transition state,
bringing the transition state
to a lower energy.
And so, often,
inhibitors that look like a
transition state will bind to
the enzyme quite tightly.
And you want the inhibitor to
bind tightly,
because you don't want
substrate to be able to come
along and displace the
inhibitor.
If you are trying to stop the
enzyme from working,
you want a tightly-bound
inhibitor, so they often look to
the transition state.
And let me just give you one
example that has been pretty
successful, and that is with
protease inhibitors.
Protease inhibitors are used in
the treatment of HIV.
The proteases are enzymes which
cleave peptide bonds.
And so we talked about the
formation of a peptide bond.
This is a reaction that
catalyzes the reverse process,
breaking down the peptide bond.
And so here might be a
simplified reaction mechanism.
You have something coming and
attacking.
Here is your peptide bond.
You are forming a tetrahedral
intermediate here.
And what would be the angles of
a tetrahedral intermediate?
109.5.
And then this would break down
and you would form these two
products, so the peptide bond
then gets cleaved.
And so designers of inhibitors
or pharmaceutical drugs have
tried to mimic this tetrahedral
intermediate to try to get tight
binding.
You have the idea that
molecules with this stable
tetrahedral site that cannot be
cleaved could bind to the enzyme
more tightly than substrate.
And this is just one example of
a drug that inhibits HIV
protease that has that stable
tetrahedral site where that
cannot be cleaved.
I am almost done.
Here is a picture of it bound
to the enzyme.
Here is the inhibitor bound to
the active site.
It fits quite well in there.
And let me just mention,
finally, that one problem with
designing inhibitors toward
enzymes, there are,
in this case,
many proteases.
You might not want to stop all
proteases from working.
You only want to stop the HIV
protease from working.
There are a lot of issues of
specificity.
That is one of the
complications of drug design.
And that, again,
is another important area for
you to think about doing.
There is still a huge problem
with HIV.
Not as much in the U.S.,
but in other countries.
That is something else you can
think about doing.
All right.
See you Wednesday.